استكملت السعوديه مشروع تصنيع وتوطين
منظومه الزوارق الاعتراضيه السريعه اتش اس
اي 32 الذي ياتي ضمن اهداف السعوديه
بتوطين ما يزيد عن خمسين في المئه من
اجمالي الانفاق الحكومي على المعدات
والخدمات العسكريه بحلول عشرين ثلاثين
الزورق الاعتراضي مشاهدي السريع اتش اس اس
اي 32 يمكنه القيام بعملياته البحريه مع
المروحيات الزورق الذي يبلغ طوله 32 مترا
وبعرض سبعه امتار يمكنه الابحار بسرعه تصل
الى 98 كيلو مترا في الساعه كما يمكن لهذا
النوع من الزوارق مشاهدينا السريعه
استيعاب طاقم مكون من 12 فردا الزورق
السريع اتش اس اي 32 مجهزون بانظمه متطوره
مثل رادارات البحث اضافه الى اجهزه
استشعار بصريه
كهربائيه كما تم تسليحه برشاش من عيار 20
ملي مترا بالاضافه الى مدفعين يغطيان
زاويه
360 درجه ويمكن لهذا الزورق مشاهدينا
تنفيذ العمليات العسكريه البحريه اضافه
الى القيام بعمليات البحث والانقاذ وحمايه
السفن ومكافحه القرصنه